well welcome welcome to your mom's house
[Music]
with the ever-increasing demand for
greater speeds and necessary
[Music]
[Applause]
Marty
yes
heart
[Music]
but we welcome guests too I mean that's
just I think I appreciate that clip even
more I do too and I you know I actually
think by the way that is called that is
called Canadian denim it's by Garrett
herder that's the I think that he
actually is the ultimate dad boner and
here's why we can get lost in the
rihanna go ahead because you can get
involved in the reactions right and
think that that's really what it is but
it's actually really about the reaction
to the whatever circumstance right and
so some people are actually reacting in
huge ways but to truly astounding things
in other words you know the whales
coming out of the water and they're guys
like oh my god or normal reaction
because it truly is remarkable
sure or when the guy in the plane sees
the eclipse and he's like oh my her I
forget the wrong I mean he gets excited
and but that's a phenomenal thing that
he's seeing these guys react like this
to a fucking highway so I think he's
actually the biggest dad boner of all
because so it's the level of dad boner
is directly proportional to the stimuli
right so some people have reacted even
bigger than a few because he sounds like
he's coming
but still it's to a highway you know
yeah who gets back yeah I mean it's all
the story like this road cow come on I
mean it sounds like he's drugged yeah
okay do you think it's a mental illness
I think this guy is something wrong with
yeah sure but you know I don't know if
he's if he's truly like I want to say
he's mentally ill to like kind of poke
at him yeah but I think this guy's were
really this excited I think it's
actually genuine he's it that's him for
real right
Oh running down the street on the
highway
oh we pointed out it's very similar
she's somebody Oh God coming really cool
you know do you think it's because maybe
he was watching them build it for so
long like maybe that's his route to work
every day
I think his level his real excitement is
infrastructure highways
that's his jam so when he sees the where
the the fucking highway ends or where it
meets whatever yeah he gets that fucking
exciting ya know
everyone's got to have something they do
it's amazing as amazing yeah I'm sober
I'm so excited to be here I spent the
last 48 hours in a Courtyard Marriott
how is that really exciting I mean it
was really neat just to sit in the brown
room and then I forget how boring the
days are for standup yeah I forgot about
that like you have to just fill hours of
time yeah and I didn't do a good job I
just sat in my room and I watched
Netflix all day and slept well I think
maybe you did do a good job maybe not
give me I mean how are you supposed to
do it I think maybe you do you do a lot
more on the road you're like all I
worked out I the workouts big to me on
the road I got to do it I actually at
the point I'm at this point now I won't
do a show without it yeah see you're
good that that part but I mean I do it I
like to do it two hours before showtime
Wow that's when I start to sleep
that's when I start my nap really five
o'clock mm-hmm no I have a 7 o'clock 5
o'clock I'm in the gym this way I can
now I can workout and I don't try to
kill myself I try to do enough where I'm
like I'm sweating
heart rates definitely up but I'm not
exhausted and in this way I feel really
alert so that then I can go back to my
room I not to panic shower change get
ready and then it's like you know I have
15-20 minutes to get to the venue yeah
that's not how my day went my day is I
have two beds there's one that you sleep
in and the other one you eat in
and I ordered postmates and I ate I do
like the separate bed and I wonder stuff
yes that put all your bullshit you turn
the air off no shutdown no wait now
you're very suspicious of is I saw your
insane post and on Instagram where you
showed that in Sacramento this week yeah
heat on in your room 76 I like it a
balmy six yeah but that feels good to me
it feels natural normal I don't like I
hate cold air we ever had a dispute in
court they would they would bring that
as evidence for the divorce the judge
would rule against you you're like well
this is a great just for that yeah the
gavel come down what about the integers
a big yeah but what about what about
what I tolerate as a wife like a lot of
your boxer shorts sitting do what I did
you know you were gone and I thought
about you eisah cuz I'm not even
listening to my argument nothing the
farting the belching and snoring shits
the constant shitting you're always
excusing yourself to shit you've been
doing it much more than I have if you
want to be honest about it what how are
we more nning that every morning we're
hanging out as a family and you're like
oh I gotta go shit you always leave the
shit first used to get it like seven
o'clock and one healthier than you know
no you're gone a long time
healthy people shit quickly if it I
thought I have to check Instagram I got
a look at the Twitter I got it hiragana
long tell you really are grinding them
out I guess it doesn't take long to come
out my Road dumps are very can I tell
you what gave me listen if you're having
trouble taking a shit yeah let me tell
you what will kick out your jams go to
Starbucks by the instant coffee at
Starbucks I drink those on the road
instead of the swill that they call
coffee at the Courtyard Marriott and I
shit like footlong really yeah dude
really proud of you sorry what were you
going to say though I don't know you
kind of lost me in all this time up oh
yeah yeah oh so I I like talk more about
Starbucks and coffee and I slept in your
in your spot and how was that it was
great it was great and then uh one night
right before I went to bed I sat like I
sat up and I clipped my toenails
in the bed and then I just brush them to
your side of the floor no yeah that's so
rude I what you do that's a picture
you're going like like stepping on them
and that's not nice it made me happy
babe that's not what's open the Shoukry
time yeah we got to do this here we go
I'm so rude how do you folks out hell
y'all doin old catfish Cooley coming
into you live baby you think it's gonna
help us a lot of people are talking
about my dog oh he just got a food and
my dog really just kind of food because
it's cost more I want to test that out I
think it's bullshit who is my auntie
don't bring anyone love into this no
more motherfucker welco welcome to your
mom's house with Tom Segura Christina
position
[Music]
yeah I think our son has more teeth than
this guy
this guy doesn't have a lot of teeth but
he's a big burly dude and he's tired of
people talking of comparing dog foods
are saying like yeah a dog doesn't like
that yeah I don't think that that's not
true like my dad my dog doesn't like I
think people I think that does happen
my dogs I've always just eaten whatever
slop we put in their bowl like no it's
similar to how you I was probably true
but I think some people do are big into
that saying like oh my dogs a big fan of
this I guess yeah I won't eat that or
doesn't like them now he's got a number
8 on this knuckle other two more age to
see a Heil Hitler the 1880s with the
white supremacist um it's the eighth
letter of the alphabet remember we
learned that revant honest this revant
honest yeah because there was somebody
with an 888 tattoo and he this is when
he was in studio and he's like eight is
it's H all right safe letter of the
alphabet well we know our ABCs Heil
Hitler
what straight-8 c c d e f g h i don't
know if he has all three that'd be
really disturbing if he did well i mean
i if the shoe fits you q sound like
someone don't say hi Heather
he's family the kind of guy that would
have yeah well I don't know if that's
fair to people that sound like that
there's a lot of people of salamanca mom
named ding dong dang man I'm okay later
see Danny had Danny's not from the South
no she says it totally differently to
[Music]
kind of sleepy yeah I got some mighty
dog food some kind of mighty yes jeepers
can mighty dog I wouldn't eat mighty dog
at least I ate it I didn't know we were
going there and the clay oh my god he
wasn't looking room boy is it done I
think so there we go no no no we're all
right now you're going in for number one
different one though I can't even do
this I get different time ago a while I
can go back way goodbye for a second
because he's making a video know what oh
my gosh why are you over this funny I
think first of all I didn't sometimes I
look at clips I had no idea this was
coming I swear to you I have no idea
you said you've seen right I've seen the
just the beginning
wait kind of dog food I tried
that's fiefs prescription that's how do
you have vomit that's scientists I until
diet or whatever because he's got you
know but that guy that worked at the at
the dog food place said I know don't eat
that because he said it's got maggots
and stuff but I got a nice ring misses
you I did give you a nice ring it didn't
taste that bad I don't know what this
fucking hillbilly is all crying about I
like him I knew it no matter what kind
of dog loses my sister
like shit oh my god do you think he'd be
used to eating like raccoon and snake
and they have an NBA or all be fun hang
out let's just say on that on this side
here man you read it it's time
it's that L it's Stewie is not Stewie
from the Family Guy it is it's really
weird
oh yeah you're right II maybe it says
catchphrase that's crazy
look at least I did it for a ring yes I
did it just for those come on yeah ha ha
ha you just did it for like YouTube
yeah like well that was a very
entertaining video I would tell man
that's very entertaining dog was not bad
bad what's this fucking sissy crying
about yeah I don't know um you know like
in pussy you hit the road and you're
hitting the road again yeah I'm going to
fart Nick's heart Nicks and then I've
been single dad I was doing it ever you
been I left you alone for exactly 48
hours and now you're a full single day I
doing good 48 hours what happened while
I was gone
uh we had a good time actually it's
really fun right yeah sometimes it's
good mean yeah there's obviously really
trying moments and mints and the I think
the thing that wears on you the wears on
nerves is when the whining doesn't stop
yeah when you hear like mm why do you
want this you want that do you want the
other thing that we when you offer
everything up no rest do you want change
do you want food like and that goes on
and on that's when you're like I'm
alright yeah tap down anyone else coming
over to help
yeah yeah so I understand that well it's
hard to see he only knows a few words so
right can't communicate this one and
yeah that amount sometimes they don't
know what they want that's the other
thing they just want you to fix it yeah
he comes all ranges fix me sometimes
they're tired but you don't you think
that oh you want to sleep and they do
but they don't know that they need to
work to get to sleep shit like they
don't know how to yeah it's tough it
wears on you
good job it's but there's a lot of fun
moments yeah you just fuckin little kid
yeah but I had a lot of fun with him you
know the only the times I get start
doubter like excuse me nighttime like if
he doesn't sleep through the night and
then I'm up with it all night and then I
have to be within the next day alone
then I'm like I want to blow my brains
out
yeah there's your on tastic it's just
but the good news is that you got a lot
of Chicot ention at the mall out of
Country Club I got to tell you something
it's so funny it's interesting I take
them to the country club and you know
for people that don't know here out here
if you like why you could go in the mall
for us it's like we live in a very hot
city and it's the heat has already begun
it's like in the 90s like today it's 93
his that let me check my Apple watch
ticking I was in the car they said in
the car that one anyways and then the
other day over the weekend it was really
windy like trees blew down oh yeah
so that is one of the reasons we go and
it's like it's you know it's space it's
it's a taking take you can get a run
free there stuff for kids you can get
lunch at lunch so anyways we go there
and I notice that I'm getting a lot of
different types of looks I'm getting
like dudes that are like like I'll say
three guys are having coffee together at
a place looking at me like see that guy
like that's what the look is look is
like see that guy with the baby the
kidnapper the kidnapper or like sound
like a woman right no that's that's how
I read their look and I noticed that
it's a different look like they don't
register a guy with a three or a five
year old like that like a kid that's up
and running and but when it's a like our
kids 16 months their lives huh
women two would look at me curiously
like because I'm sitting there you know
I'm putting him back in the stroller
because he gets tired of running and I'm
pulling a part of banana giving a piece
of banana
yeah here's your water like I'm doing
all the caretaking thing doing mom
thinks and they're looking at me like
yeah where did this guy steal this mom
mom does ever like no offense but mom is
really I I get it but if the OGS and
your interest really real look
get from strangers and it tells you a
lot it tells you a lot about you know so
society yeah and also these individuals
I mean some of them are looking at me
because they think that I even I
shouldn't be doing that yeah well and
that's the thing is that people assume
women are natural caregivers yeah and
that's really not true because you have
I to learn how to take care of an infant
it's not like it comes out of you and
you're like oh I know how to breastfeed
like know someone had to come to our
house and teach me how and then I to
learn how to change a diaper so it's
learned behavior and men can learn it
too and I don't know why the fuck the
default is mom all the time on every
well I know why it makes sense actually
it came out of me which yeah and because
as a woman and also don't forget you're
the actual food source and I'm talking
about getting very more but from the
beginning the woman is the food source
yeah it makes sense because we're
programmed biologically for you to have
the life grows in you and then you yeah
nurture it so it's not that crazy but
it's interesting that you know obviously
people and times have evolved and people
are looking at me like what the fuck are
you doing I mean he stole baby yeah it
looked at me like I was crazy and I
could you know I wasn't like one or two
people talking about multiple people
throughout this our chat them all we're
looking at me like what are you doing I
know it's sad when people when men are
like I'm gonna babysit I'm babysitting
my children this weekend when my wife
goes away it's like you're not
babysitting asshole those are your kids
but sure yeah why is that the assumption
that only mom can take care of children
I think men should be offended that it's
assumed to be a female role I mean don't
you get some satisfaction taking care of
Ellis I of course I get satisfaction no
it's great I mean like I know I'm doing
woman's work right right but I still I
still enjoy just like if you were to
fucking build a deck you'd be like oh
this is cool with location right or just
what humans can do ya know I feel like
people can do it I don't know despite
having like like if I cook him a hard
cool like chicks do this you know you
could you could excellent I did have a
great Sunday cooking day well wait what
was it called the brisket
is that what you mean oh I did try to
dictate that was so good that tip was
god damn that was amazing I got a big
green egg for some another some super
barbecue fans out there I like to work
with fire so I don't like doing you know
I like charcoal I like wood chips I like
I like messing with fire and this thing
is it's really it's really simple
actually because you control your heat
just based on the air you let into it so
you can you can basically get this thing
if you want to let's say throw a steak
on and you want to just have that thing
go quick you can make you can make the
thing about almost 700 degrees and just
have the vents completely open by your
penis and it's like a fucking you know
almost like a broiler and then boom your
steak is done in a minute you know but
you can also reduce the airflow and
bring that temperature in that 225-250
range and slow cook some things and
that's what I did with that it was so
it's smokey tasting today your smokey
does yeah look you can't you can't like
smoke a cake in there you can you can
smoke a cake absolutely really you
missed it while you were gone I did a
couple of birthday cakes in there really
no some cupcakes like smoking chocolate
people love that that natural that
charcoal tasting cake is like it's just
such a its own it's on its uncommon but
it's it's really rewarding yeah
interesting no but I actually did do a a
British baking show treat I tried it
that was awesome yeah because we found
the secondary show the master class they
had on Netflix and you can watch Mary
berry Mary power and Paul Hollywood
mania recipe always would and you know
what I noticed when I was watching it
and that Paul Hollywood is like a big
show-off like he cracked the eggs with
one hand on the side well he does it
fast too kind of likes like showing off
yeah and he does everything really
really fast to show off and Mary Barry
was like I've noticed when you crack it
that way all the egg drips on the side
of the bowl and he you know she was
like relax relax read a bag take it take
it down a notch you know but that's the
that's it kind of contributes to the
chemistry of them right because yeah
like t notice none of the egg drew who's
on my phone
and he's like that's fine that like it
doesn't even he's like yeah it's just
like you are with your mom basically
yeah okay mom
he made a couple of old jokes at her at
one point and she did not react like a
couple of she was like nope it she did
not like it so I tried his chocolate
volcano yeah I missed one small but key
step yeah I forgot the two tablespoons
of flour
goddamnit I could just see him trying it
and being like the flavors there yeah
it's a good bike a good bike here you
didn't get the rise you should have
gotten you know you need to get that
that molten lava cake rise and for those
of you like oh you guys are back on the
fat train we literally we did it like
bakers we had a couple bites through the
night fucking threw it away
yeah I made Fitness today i rein it in
yeah we're all good
got to make Fitness make it all the time
I made it I made it four times last week
and I'll make Fitness is yeah morning
I'm going to do I'm going to do twice
with the trainer and I'm going to do a
couple solos this week kind of turning
into like that mom life that I got going
you just Pilates twice a week yeah take
care of a kid alone now I'm pretty
exciting yeah it's pretty good dating
now there's one thing that you know we
got a lot of email things to go through
one thing that's been coming up is like
personality-wise okay I mean it really
is the chance I don't I you're not going
to read lists or emails are you because
those are always really slanted towards
one of us or they don't really know us
in real life oh my god you say I got one
better for you okay I have actual
commentary no I was listening to this
podcast contest personality and it for
me is not even it is not a contest it's
by far by far by her you're the best
christine has a really nice personality
yo he's really smart road is not the
venue but I've had a charming amazing
timing articulate and all the things
around you win by part we're a great
great ladies knock on Tara
you're gonna now lie but wait a minute
that's not some random color that's your
biological mom that's the woman that
raised you how about somebody that knows
us both she's supposed to feel that
about people to know us both
you know I mean these other people
didn't have it that's your mom
what's up Teddy loons hey I was just
listening to the pocket yourself look
you know I love Christina what dozen
years Ryan Sickler yeah I know I know
this is beautiful girl great mom
hilarious comedian yeah um great friend
great daughter uh-huh
when it comes to personality cardboard
I'll just dry a ship sandpaper
yep really nothing there's definitely
married off and when it comes to
personality you definitely have a better
person I can't believe you solicit fire
that was Ryan Sickler of the crab feast
podcast yep he's a what a traitor I
can't believe it there's this I mean
people are yeah calling in now those are
people those are too biased people that
you set up anybody listen to the show
interesting question who has the best
personality well I think that what
Cristina is clearly yeah the more
intelligent in her educational
background he's so into that I think in
terms of personality after all you're my
son oh yeah say ah oh you know you got
with most of your personality for me
yeah so we're joined for you so I think
that my vote has to go to you I'm unreal
unreal I mean it's obviously skewed I
don't know I mean there's people I mean
obviously my parents are gonna vote say
one of his pay homage to that poster on
a full charge I was thinking about this
lately I don't know why we're thinking
about it that the wife Perseus Oh
quality on stage on stage but I'll say
that I kind of think you have a better
personality there you're fun to hang out
with yeah you always got the joke yep
like offstage just I like hanging out
with you man you know yeah
please don't tell Kristina I said that
Wow wow this is really quite a cool here
well so I mean I'm devastated I can't
believe it it is kind of alarming doctor
go go see if I'm at the park for my kid
oh this is he a podcast I thought about
what you said on there I'd say so
at the end of the day unless you take it
I'm a guy that's personality I'm not
gonna believe because we have the body
so talk to say that but you do have a
nice personality inside and wispy she's
a great mom good-looking broad you know
funny comic personalities kind of like
ah you don't say that Hungarian they got
the goulash and the swords it jumping up
and down shit so your personalities kind
of smooth Christine you know I won't you
don't stab me in the head I don't know
what's going out there you go have what
I think thank you for what it's worth
safe life so do you feel like can't
believe this I know it's kind of it is
crazy but you feel like this is because
these are all people that are more
connected to me is that what you're
saying I'm saying I just have a feeling
that you solicited these comments these
are just people they called anything
anything I you know so weird that they
everyone all of our friends are
listening or pie gasps and then felt
compelled to call and leave a voicemail
about that's how it goes I don't know I
mean but how do you think like do you
think if you had if we had like your
people calling it would be different
though or no you think
tell me what you did oh yeah Sean yeah I
heard there was like a discussion about
who's a personality chanda or side wind
I mean I've known Christina since I was
15 yeah I loved her for her personality
or Robert of death then when I met Tom I
mean when they got married I was like
wow this guy's got a great personality I
gotta say personality champ Tom Segura
okay
that's your best doesn't that's terrible
best I can't believe you did that to her
I got my doing pay her I don't pay or
anything you did I did not I'm gonna
find out how much you paid her Elaine
hey or a dime Oh Mikey called I know you
did you sent them glass and t-shirts for
free no I did we sent her and her
husband Jimmy free t-shirts and that's
why they did that I got that I know that
dude no no I know why I think it's
pretty much it feels settled to me do
the people that know us both even the
listeners obviously side more towards me
I know it's the way everybody who
commented knows it nobody knows us
that's interesting they're voting
they're voting with their voices babe
okay so I think setting it's time to
throw in the towel on this one
something tells me you've manipulated
the data hi this is Steve Paul and I'm
just listening to the podcast and wanted
to chime in my buddy Steve I must say
when it comes to looks Kristina by far
the much better-looking person is that
Bob the SEM no contest at all I mean I
today however personality-wise I got to
get to the top yeah there you go
this is so stupid how is it stupid I
mean it's so obviously manipulated they
manipulated this is these are
alternative facts everybody knows no
it's not that it's so stupid what you
feel done with it now no I don't feel
that in fact this compels me to continue
the dialogue and I'm going to take it to
the streets and I'm with them really
really interview people from now on
really yeah do you really think that
anybody would side with you yes
everybody who knows those unbiased
people maybe not family members or best
friends you've manipulated yeah well it
seems like one of yours
sided with me when you're best friends
you paid her
free t-shirt not a her you paid her in
fee she sent me a picture in hourglass
and shirts last night and I thought well
that's weird that's odd
no she doesn't normally you know by
merge from us and then now makes perfect
sense you sent her those shirts and you
bribed her I was pretty great though do
another funny thing can't believe you
did this Holland though this is 220 you
are so no no yes it's like down a two
carbon compound reacts with a four
carbon compound to produce the six
carbon compounds citric acid LSI in
subsequent reactions two carbons are
lost as co2 electrons are stored and ATP
is produced damn it you know I never
even took chemistry because I couldn't
get past the first like week of it I did
and the guy fucking loved me and that's
why he gave me a deed he loved me
I should've he was a little hard he
didn't love you he probably loved how
hot you were in high school you know you
hit father so and so I was somebody that
treated him like a human being yeah you
know I treated the teacher like a person
I had real conversations and you could
tell that nobody did that so he was so
engaged with me and I I really this is
like an extension of my awesome
personality right more manipulation some
might say a manipulative personality
glad he loved me and I remember he could
not hit over how bad I was at chemistry
and he did in a subtle way he wasn't
obvious but he you could see on his face
like don't you get this and I'm like no
I could not get it to save my life I
mean in high school I could not I had to
drop out and take two different classes
to count as chemistry if that's what you
had to do that in order to I don't know
be a value in this world oh my god be a
fucking bottom-feeder I mean yeah just
be I'd be living in the cardboard
clogging in a gutter
Bangladesh's Isaac have you been all day
that's the dirtiest place I know that is
not the dirtiest it's the worst place on
earth why do you say that because I've
seen photos you're horrible no where do
you think this is related of your
personality where do you think the worst
place on earth is be real and not
obviously Toledo how dare you the
Perrysburg your honeymoon
I've not been to Erie um no no I don't
know the worst I mean
on earth not now USA nothing's that bad
in the u.s. I think Bangladesh I mean no
I wouldn't have said been with
Kyrgyzstan I've been there it's terrible
not as bad if you know what's funny when
I was in Hong Kong which is amazing
yeah a lot of native people they were
telling me don't go to mainland China
you think oh no that seriously I think
I'll go outside of the cities of China
yeah yeah they were like I've heard that
too
Rock yeah it's real these were Chinese
people telling me this they're like
don't go okay there they thought they
thought we were going to have you guys
going to Shanghai and stuff we're like
no and they're like well don't you know
don't venture outside of there yeah I've
heard there's a lot of like toothless
people people with five legs and two
heads yeah you know two heads well I see
that a lot on the on the Instagram like
I fall on that GL on Instagram just such
as oh and they're and they're like this
baby was born with five legs and two
heads from India it's never America that
was five-legged baby
yeah I'm really I just have to say I'm
really amused by your quote consensus of
who's got a better personality it's a
very binary don't very amusing doing
here the funniest part of this whole
thing though yeah so when I called and I
told my parents to call in yo so here's
like to manipulate the data I go here's
a set up and do it so my dad calls and
he acts like uh he's just a regular
caller so I had to have him call twice
because the first time hilarious as if
the listeners would not know how yet so
he first started a hate Tom just want to
offer my opinion on who the personality
winner so any kid he can't say it right
either person a personality winner and
he goes hey Tom so I called back and I
go what was that listen
and he goes well your mom said to so
that the people don't know it's me like
I go do you guys don't think that that
not only with the listeners no but that
like we wouldn't play it'd be like oh
that's your dad yeah you can hide who
that
yes I thought so but he just left it as
I'm dish hey Tom just wanted a job
economist I go you never called me never
not even violent I've never heard him
call you that it's always a buddy buddy
buddy me yeah big dog yeah
never Tom now the funny part too
actually is that our interior designer
was here this morning showing us plans
and I waited she waited and we're a
really good relationship with her she's
very funny
and I go forgive Tom he's late he's just
not a very good personality and I go and
I go Shana
that's her name's you what who do you
think has a better personality Tom er me
yeah and at first she gave the very
considerate like well you guys are both
and I was and she Brown come on and
here's what she said do you think I am
have a better personnel now should some
more people know that's better kinder to
more people
that doesn't make you money are more
selective of who you are kind to in
other words you withdraw and restrict
being kind yeah selectively yes whereas
I am that way with more people jeez I
wonder which of the two of us as a
better Brown hold on Jana allowed me to
defend here's why a I'm a woman if I
walk around being all googly star ID and
kind every a hole out there you guys
think you're hitting on them if you're
nice to them and I had to learn that in
my 20s I think you learned it this
weekend - and I do yeah I got hit on
actually twice in the airport my wedding
ring is not big enough so the second
part to that is I grew up in a major
city with a lot of me hi sorry what's
your name what's your pronoun so what
happened the second part is that when
you grow up in LA there's a lot of nut
bags here that come from other places so
you got to put up the shield first and
then then if you're cool that I'm nice
now but I'm nice to servers I'm nice to
to everybody I just don't go out of my
way to be kind kinda like hey I'd be my
friend
yeah not until I know you okay no I'm
not rude to like service people that I
never said you were rude to sometimes
like that's what I'm saying like I would
never ever be shitty to like service
you're obviously not very kind of the
Ben
does she people oh they're not listening
they don't think so they don't have I
phones like oh I didn't hear right now I
know they did
no they don't no no no I'm sound like
Yoshi no no no by the way oh I got to
make this announcement so the live Yoshi
episode went up I saw some complaints
about the audio luckily we got an email
from a guy named Malcolm in Seattle who
volunteered an idea to fix it yeah and
blue band did it and it was a thousand
percent improved well thank you welcome
if you tried listening and you're like I
don't like this audio this sucks you
stop please give it another shot
here's what you have to do though this
is what I've been told is that if you
downloaded it you have to delete it and
download a second time because the feed
has a new file in it so that it's the
live episode it went up on Friday
Yoshi joined us and he's crazier and
shit crazy a great guest great great
good now back to this Bangladeshi thing
just you know I had an Indian stepfather
for 79 I have a black friend that's well
no it's not the thing and he hated India
he only ever told me horror stories
about growing up in Bombay yeah Mumbai
horrible horrible so all I ever heard
was what a dump
India was and how much better America is
and suggesting you know I've got a
fucking witness I'm not I'm not in the
stands it's fine your mum's no but
really where do you think the worst
place on rental is let's let's go it's a
really great question I mean I think the
worst place on earth is hot in India go
ahead Joe as hot rain do that dirty
check to and and undeniably really poor
check 3 3 4 3 it could be like that yeah
it could be that could be the place I
don't know sounds terrible I probably a
lot of Central African places ok
oh boy that's got to be rough too fuck
yeah or war-torn wait clearly long ago
oh shit man yeah that's that we need the
worst because we're talking about
reality like you go there now yeah she's
real right now so conserve yeah
you're drinking the water that
everyone's bathing in Canada ask if
there's water and then yeah aside of all
like we take away the just a punishing
heat yeah the unfair extreme poverty
yeah
the disease the filth yeah when you take
away all that and then and bullets
flying overhead let's say you get away
from all that you could still turn
around and have a rhino bite you in half
true this is in Africa in certain parts
of us sure
Tigers can't swim and and and Molly oh
yeah you know what Tigers that's more of
an India problem isn't India problem I
thought it was in Africa thing yeah yeah
and also the civility I've heard stories
where a pedestrian will be hit in the
road in India somewhere and they'll just
keep driving over them like people don't
pull over oh that's also has to do with
population human life is not valued yeah
yeah once you get once you have a
country with over 1 billion people
imagine if we had yeah like right now we
had 4 times as many people as we have
right now in the States you would they
would report things like you'd report
the others last 'back that's less yeah
you'd be like it's a lot of people if
people are fucked up people die that's
how you me you wouldn't even have to
tell somebody if you hit a pedestrian oh
you'd be like my keep driving to go
which guy oh the guys yet I said that's
nothing and you know what I noticed you
when I was like in the Middle East is
that people just walk on the freeway
yeah there's a lot of that too like
camels just run next to the freeway
people walk well or not I should walk
yeah you don't give a fuck yeah we're
gonna get some emails next well sure I'm
sure
what you tell people yeah lot of stuff
coming up I do I'm excited I'm wrapping
up to take my hour special so I'm
running it now please come see it that
loud enough and May 4th and 5th part
next Arizona at stand-up arrived may 19
through 20th jus dork titties at Gotham
come on you Club June 1 through 3 Denver
lumber hang vert Denver Comedy Works the
downtown location just
16th and 17th man friend disco at the
punch rang comedy krub oh and I just
added June 22nd I'm going to run it one
last time here at flip airs in Burbank
in the yoohoo room
June 22nd so come check that that's
great Bert the flappers that you who
room is this shit I love that I love
small room yeah I know you're not
supposed to but I always prefer them
said it that's a gene right I'm going to
be going back to Oregon the great state
of Oregon Oregon Oregon new jeans Oregon
blue jeans Oregon blue jeans I like that
one by the way we added a show May 12th
in Eugene go ducks so Ryan Sickler is
coming with me he'll be on both of the
shows on the 12th and you team tickle
Sal yeah sickle cells cook Williams and
then the 13th we go back to Portland
Oregon and the reason I did that was
because the first two I did sold out
really far ahead of time so we're doing
two more on May 13th get your tickets
that early show sold out but there are
tickets available to the Late Show
I believe that's at 10:30 on May 13th
then I go to tux in Arizona Reno Nevada
renown seam semen Aquila California at
the chango's no I got it we got it in
that's June 11th at the Pechanga and
then I go to the dirty dirty I go to
Richmond Virginia Virginia Virginia
Beach Virginia jeans borough North
Carolina cheap at the cone denim
entertainment center oh my god and I
know you did that on purpose right worse
you requested that venue July 14th
Asheville North Carolina Asheville is a
Scott it yeah and July 15th I don't know
what to call Charleston South Carolina
I know Tesla and Charles tank Karl Fink
I don't know
then this 27 tampon beach New Hampton
Hampton tampon Wilmington I don't know
Delaware Wellington I don't know what
that is
baldon whores Maryland on July 29 right
Falls and horse yeah and then I go to my
Australia and that's all at Tom Segura
calm / tour of course we do the podcast
live one show only August 23rd it's a
long ways away but it is it is moving
and that is in West Falls Beach Florida
at The Improv in Palm Beach so make sure
to get your tickets now so you were
struttin that ass struttin that ass at
the airport how dare you and guys were
like hey and you were like hey no I
wasn't like hey what happened was I'm
wearing I don't wear a big chunky garish
yeah diamond ring I just went doesn't
work I have a very tender little wedding
band that says missus hmm I love this
thing yeah it's cool subtle and I don't
think it stands out enough because twice
I got kind of like talk so how does it
work because I imagine I'll just tell
you I imagined that that that happens to
you on my mind all the time they guys I
know how guys operate
you see attractive woman you just go hey
right yeah well tell you what's a really
big cock shrinker is a one-year-old in
your arm well I know when I'm Jonna I'm
assuming when I'm talking about when
you're not with I know child um I
usually look like hell when I travel and
this time I had gone to Alan I got my
hair done and it was it was blown out
nicely yeah so I think like I was not
made up but I looked like a civilized
human and but I don't send out any kind
of signal like I'm down eyes forward
usually ear buds very shut off like I'm
very cold in public that is true like I
don't I'm not kind as you say to
everybody so I'm in the security line
and that's the first guy who's about my
age you know he's alone and he's doing
the whole who has more
Bank Airport is really easy huh and I'm
like yeah yeah ah this is so much better
than Texas and it where are you going
like doing the whole the Chatty Cathy
and then you're like oh yeah I'll tell
you now yeah yeah I was like what
husband what kid and I hid the screen
photo I have genuine Ella's like
immediately I change it I changed it and
then you know I shot it down though I
don't really want to get into it and
then I was on self worst airline and we
were lining up like animals and the guy
behind me did where you going a business
or pleasure how long are you staying in
Sacramento how do you handle it well in
California first of all we don't do that
like that just a southern thing maybe
not in LA nobody talks to people and
that like you it's just forbidden it's
against the rules yeah I won't decide
okay so I know what I do is I answer
politely but tersely I don't give a lot
of details and by the way I don't like
people knowing where I live where I'm
going I don't like that II I'm bigger
I'm like don't ask don't ask a lot of
questions
I fuckin lie to people all the time now
the driver who drove me to the airport
yesterday didn't he's like so are you
here for business or a pleasure and I
was this close to lying and being like a
business I'm a paralegal
one night stone to school and he looked
at the sheet and he goes oh you're
comedian and I was on the punch line
arrange all right and I was two seconds
away from just lying this guy so I want
to talk about comedy or the next hour
yeah
so I'm glad I didn't lie to him cuz I
normally do and he did the whole thing
where he he looked in the rearview
mirror as he was driving forward the
whole fucking time which to me I panic
like bro look at the road like that I
don't need to make eye contact with ya
you know there's one worse than that and
that is the full turnaround that's not
yeah and this isn't a movie like you're
really driving come are you in town for
yeah like a couple day come look at that
rock up there what's that there oh the
road you fucking idiot yeah so do you
like to you to kind of flirt back
without I'm telling you this whole not
kind thing is I'm polite but I certainly
do
invite a dialogue I don't I only run all
over my face that too yeah I don't like
small talk
I really can't tolerate a lot of legs or
where's on where are you from what's
that like please can we talk about let's
talk about anything else yeah I hate
small talk I can't do it
yeah fuck I can't and I can't be polite
I can't answer things right you know
right you live in town when you're with
Ellis a lot of girls know people don't
even like I usually what they do is
they're like oh my gosh as they're
looking at him you look up at me and
they like they kind of get out of it
must be mom yes I don't like okay are
you supposed to be with this boy telling
you you mean to tell me that after shows
now because I hear stories from male
comics who are like do that' fuckin my
set was so killer I had a four-way
afterwards I sorta guy like dude there's
never been a set and then some fucking
whore afterwards like you want sex and
you're like yeah give me or never I love
sexting no no girl no woman's ever been
like you know I heard you talking about
farts up there no I was wondering even
fart in my mouth in my face that happens
yeah that happens no they don't really
that doesn't really work like that I
mean a Artie they had it rolls are so
low to my shows and they don't come in
you don't get the bachelorette party
like I'll get like like some guys like
three girls might go see this guy they
like doesn't work like that for me it's
not that you're not you know I had my
audience yeah Dane Cook would have like
a gaggle of girls go absolutely and
there's a bunch there's guys out there
now I'm sure draw women like single gut
but for me I'm telling you this happens
every show guys are bringing their girls
like the guys doing a lot of dates right
like guy takes his girl to the movies
take and then in the meet-and-greet
lines the guy will take a picture and
this happens every show goes babe and
she goes I'm good and then I go and then
he's like no come on I'm fine
no thanks no thanks for like I don't
want a photo of this that's interesting
so you think that your onstage persona
your personality is so unlikable pretty
much on
yes yeah yeah I think so yeah yeah I
have I have it all the time
and no girls do not go like hey really
no never not even like I'm not even real
about there's jokes like they they will
listen to our show yeah and though ya
know them and they'll be like I'll like
your ass like there was a whole time
where was the whole time of that people
were offering to amazing every time very
exciting to hear yeah exciting here I
was always pleased to hear it but but on
a regular basis no I don't get like hey
we're sometimes groups will say like
where are you going afterwards yeah um
and won't get hints that I don't want to
yeah we're not social I'll be like I
don't know and then they go you want to
wait here and I got now no I don't know
how long I'll be here and they're like
okay we can wait outside I'm like don't
do that and then it's like they still be
like so there's a bar across the street
yeah which one is that
and I'm like yeah yeah I might go there
never done course not
I don't like to hang out well it's so
late by the time I was done with my
shows it was like twelve thirty and the
audience is tired I'm tired I want to go
home I was thinking about I think I told
you yet
Burt posted some photo on his Instagram
yeah him with the Bachelorette group oh
my god I was carrying one of them oh my
god here was tonight and I almost texted
them like your idea of a fun night is my
idea of a panic attack yeah yeah like
that is yeah anxiety and ducing yes 100%
like remember time for media partying
with a fucking group of people and like
for him that's a show can't do it do it
can I say what gives me the most
diarrhea about an exchange like that the
amount of small talk that would have to
ensue yeah of like so what's it like
being a comedian what's it like being do
I act like I'm not really a big drinker
you know yeah I would have to get fucked
up to hang out like that we're a bunch
of bachelorettes Oh with anyone with any
group I'm saying because because of the
small talk yeah because I can't do it
sober I'd be like well I'll just fucking
knock back some shots and do this yeah
I'm so uncomfortable in in lar
groups - yeah I've never functioned with
large groups of girlfriends or parties I
never I never had a fun it's better like
in a smaller situation no no like let's
actually talk of course yeah I also
wanted to uh burnt likes to hold court
you know you don't like I can't do I
nothing makes me more comfortable than
like he's also good idea now let's do
one do that and now it's like he has all
these ideas of how the fun can continue
and I will say though that our audience
is so wonderful in that like the every
time I work somewhere the staff goes guy
you the best crowds you guys you guys
get and out I'll say it because our
crowds at live shows so respond mix own
a podcast listeners and stand-up fans
right but I feel like the reason I keep
getting compliments from venues on the
audience is because of podcast
absolutely because I get it I got it on
this whole tour everywhere I go they go
you bring in the most amazing people
yeah and at first I'm like oh you just
mean like because they laughed at the
shit like they like a show like no
they're like so respectful oh yeah you
know if it's a no heckling a heckle they
tip well they're dant they're nice they
didn't you know start any shit with
anyone they're just like good people so
they're the best and I would say that
they're the type of people I actually
probably would have a drink with like
one-on-one generally when I mean mommies
I'm like oh like you actually a normal
human being
yeah I'm friends with you yeah kind of
weird huh but then I wouldn't because
the anxiety of these social interaction
that's too much now you got an email
about that by the way what are you
really I swear I go away we talked about
this one I go away for two days and it's
like a fortress you just built up all
this ammo against me I know this is not
against you it says it actually goes
over here you but then they kind of
single you out yes I've been a mommy
since way back so no disrespect but you
guys see the two of you yeah but it's
not about you that is person really
fired up they got real fired up against
me sound so dumb low and lose when you
talk about retarded people yeah I'm
working on my degree in teaching special
ed work at a center for adults with
intellectual disabilities uh-huh
and my kid has especially every retard
retard you meet a different person with
different dreams and desires
just like you retards okay yeah some do
like white bummer movies some get
married okay some have jobs live
independently and yes they drive no it's
not pleasurable to be retarded you sound
dumb mommy Tina I'm sorry but no wait a
minute are you saying on this comedy
show
it's not serious show I sound stupid
well that's weird email yeah some of my
students fully understand the world
around and as well as their struggles I
don't know about fully and I don't think
it's fully they are retarded babe what
whatever they go people think they don't
know shit and all they do is
masturbating drool right shut the fuck
up with this Oh Sarah Sarah Sarah
alright well retard I didn't but we we
knew that they had lives we're not I
don't I don't have lives we did that we
did we just didn't know they could drive
that was a big surprise well the drive
thing and that's all on me
III first of all I thought that your
comment was insane
I was trying that like do they not know
that they're retarded I wouldn't I did I
genuinely didn't know I believe that you
genuinely said it yeah I still thought
it was crazy but my thing was I really
didn't know if they could drive but I
really hated it well yeah I know I'm
saying like I'm volunteering that she's
saying that like yeah some of them drive
like in other words you're stupid for
not knowing that I really didn't know
that
I asked genuinely I didn't think it was
possible that I thank you so either
with that little if diminished mental
capacity would you need some mental
capacity to drive that react absolutely
sign of whatever little walk away that's
a legit what about like Junction you
know I mean like where things come
together you're way old in like oh yeah
I know the rules
I mean I'm I thought that that would be
more complicated for me I'm barely not
retired but the the question as to
whether or not they
are aware that they are retiring horses
no no will hear me out let's look at
this philosophically if you are this
thing and you don't know maybe you don't
know another way of being just because
you are that way it's just like the gate
does a dog know that it's consciousness
is a dog consciousness that it's
separate from that being human is
different I don't know
feel like I want to bail you out an
animal I don't help you retire hundred
consciousness letting me I don't care I
really don't go to shit I don't care the
fuck no not really
zero fucks given about what about
whatever is somebody's upset that I you
know if I have a genuine and telling you
how come how come white why come why
can't I be curious about this you can't
be cured yes you can be curious hahaha
[Music]
somebody says you're cheating cheating
huh I'm furious this person writes I'm
not going to take it any longer
Christina put cheats key yeah teeny
cheats about what would you rather know
stop and her husband tom allows it
because of sexism and nepotism and obama
it is an outrage and a tragedy on par
with the worst crimes in history she's
basically Pol Pot when the option in
would you rather are poor and skinny or
rich and fat you cannot say you'll
choose skinny and find a rich guy no no
why oh why option is skinny and poor so
even if you did find a rich guy you
would not be able to enjoy any of his
money or the trappings of as well she
would remain in a shed in the backyard
like a proper poor person how dare you
allow this cheating to continue how dare
you I demand reparations yours forever
in love Burt but schinsky Wow Burt
that's a really good point and it a good
point thank you for bringing that to our
attention
yeah you do that you like I'll just find
this way that's the whole point of would
you rather in the Navy at the loophole
Jana I went to law school for two oh
because your prison
you're like you're skinny like this is
your life or this is your life which
life and you're like way you do it this
way there's always a workaround in life
don't you get it Tom that's not how
would you patent works I think your
honor would send you to the hole for 30
days yes sir pitching this idea and come
on
that's all that's it that's how you play
the game you have to find your work
around another email no my love you
fucking christ
taking these emails I leave today
relevant how much I suck who's making me
me
hailer I've known as he's a Gina says
plenty of can I say something
yeah can I tell you something because he
never listens Tom never listens to can I
just say yes do you think this is the
Midwestern mom translation of you know
what I'm saying
you feel me or you know what I mean
finished and done shorty George PS Chef
John might as well be a member of the
wu-tang clan because he ain't nothing to
fuck with Wow I didn't still yeah upset
about making fun - I did not know can I
tell you why don't I tell you why I say
can I say something right because you
just talk right over me you've done it
this episode like two or three times
come on yeah yeah listen to the tape I
have to interject otherwise I can't get
my fucking thought in there you really
feel that way
hello now why am I saying can I say
something because it's always because
you don't let me you move on see like
right now I'm talking you and you're
looking at a soundboard don't know the
next thing know but I'm still listening
to you know can I say oh nothing can I
just say something
the thing is we watch Sesame Street and
what does Cookie Monster learn to listen
with whole body whole body whole mine
eyes body yeah eyes wires listen here's
about any relaxed mouth shut and you
don't do that for me look even right now
you but I'm looking at the complainants
still listen to you not fully nightly
Cookie Monster live why does it have to
be exactly way can I do would you rather
real quick you wanna do would you rather
yeah go ahead just go for it it's simple
it's not it's not too complicated okay
okay would you rather live in a
Courtyard Marriott or you did where I
did yeah it's like those photos you
don't know what that is it's a Marriott
that you can actually like have a
kitchenette bathroom you know like
but kind of like living in a crummy
apartment yeah okay that's your living
situation - any communal pool maid
service or it's an RV you live Liat like
I did on road rolls Rovers place RV now
keep in mind the RV yes you can park in
RV parks you can't really park an RV
just anywhere don't think you can and if
you take a shit in that RV you have to
unload the sewage a minute yeah but I
think you could learn that pretty
quickly but it still stinks and it cooks
in the summertime the shit I mean maybe
now it's better but back in the 90s it
all was
hmm so wait what is the how long are we
living in each situation of your life so
you're either living at the Courtyard
Marriott or in the RV yeah but look like
with the RV you have mobility yeah okay
well let's change it up so let's change
it up no no no I'm making me Courtyard
Marriott more more appealing you can
live at any Courtyard Marriott location
Oh
now as you know can you have one built
just for you no but I'm saying like if
you go let's say you go I can I want to
live in you know New York City and they
don't have one can you say New York City
no oh be an existing location okay and
as you know the locations are generally
across from like a nice Chili's or maybe
down the street a mile from a Red
Lobster
sure generally not a sidewalk in front
of it so you use a busy highway the
views are of parking lots things like
that um I think I would still choose the
RV okay because you can move it you can
drive it right that's part of the appeal
to me so I think I would I would get I
would get comfortable I would learn how
to dump my sewage and maybe real stinky
I'm sure it is I'm sure it's terrible
that's the only thing I ask Brian Regan
by the way went because here's a tour
bus like a really nice tour bus so first
question yes okay I go the rules on tour
buses is like no shit like rest always
like it was like no shits now you piss
in here you can't shit in here I go so
isn't that he goes well no I shit and I
said well he doesn't say he actually was
like I know I can't I go what so doesn't
your whole bus and like shit then
because now it's like they have new
technology now where it's like this
grinding thing and it's like a hole he
goes I wouldn't get one if I couldn't
take it up he was like this is all you
want to talk about so I kept talking
yeah looks fascinating because airplanes
they have to unload the septic tank to
after every flight and if you have
anybody that tours that is like the one
of the first things it's always like hey
I said she was a group you know a band
touring or five good friends you're like
we are not dumping here now yeah can you
have five guys constantly shitting on
your tour bus forgetting I see now
here's the other thing with the RV part
that are the RV that you don't maybe not
think about as a professional I've lived
on one you can't like I said you need
electricity to plug into at night so
you're not you're not parking your
trailer necessarily in just in front of
any residential street something I'll
call the cops you have to go to RV parks
to plug in to get your amenity to shower
you know yeah now RV parks sometimes are
not that nice you're among special
different people yeah you know some of
them are nice in Australia like some of
them were super nice like there's one in
Malibu that overlooks the oceans like a
billion-dollar RV park elitist yeah of
course yeah not LA so anyway that's not
LA who knows what the situation will be
like yeah that's true would you how do
you feel that tour bus would you do it
yeah yeah yeah so do you think you are
though the can I say something can I
just say something yeah I guess because
is there a supercut no there's none oh
okay yeah interesting but me and your
preparation for today's show Don
Kristina episode there isn't a super
catch me not a shit on Christina have a
sure is how I get sure feels like it
people like my personality and Alison is
she never seen episode and you just been
really you know you I think you're a
little angry that I left in this weekend
on moving on I am open dick there's just
a little bit of you right there it's not
me you know what thank you you know what
I'm saying yeah that's you you know you
know who that you know champ is it's a
kid from Harvard he's a hockey player
Tyla thanks for being here about the
keys to the game with facing Duluth
tomorrow yeah I think you know the main
thing
is going to be managing the environment
obviously we've got a great opportunity
here and you know a lot of fans and
Kyler's more on everything but you know
just managing that and what's up and the
key to this role yeah you know to you
know to create that kind of culture
where you know we told each other
accountable yeah you know in to you know
to get up for big games and I think that
that's been something that we've been
able to draw from and you know like I
said before we go we've got a great
opportunity here you know what you know
and you know we know there so we can you
know you're like but you know you know -
you know you know you know I you know
this you know like you know all right
yeah you know and you know you know
right now just a communications major
I'm guessing uh you know you know you
know we've you know we've obviously got
a great opportunity here Wow
so we had an ivy league an Ivy League
you know that's a big that's a big step
we never had a Harvard one
now we haven't that's a that's quite a
unique thing to have a Harvard level you
know champ very special can i you know
saying just say you know saying that
thanks to everybody that downloaded
mostly stories the album you may be
number one on iTunes and I got the
physical copies
I signed a bunch of them today and
they're at the in the store so if you
want an autographed a hard copy of the
album it has two bonus tracks I put that
in the store it's in the soil right now
I also went to Risa or sign the
remaining glass and posters like so if
you want to do black and poster that's
funny it's autographed the the rest of
autograph the rest now you kindly
offered me an autographed copy of mostly
stores thank you for that yeah I did my
opportunity and and I keep getting asked
everyone says vinyl what about vinyl
there is going to be a vinyl release in
June of mostly stories so if you're
waiting for vinyl I'll announce it a big
thing then but it is going to be in June
hmm and that'll come with a little side
little present with it
Oh present hey did you want to hear my
new foreign voicemail is there any way
we could listen to it uh yeah you can
hear it set tell me what your voicemail
it is let me just make sure it can't you
can't transcribe it Apple it's fine it's
the top one the top one two one three
numbers okay yeah I got a brand new
looks like I have a brand new follow me
cuz we lost her Salome is gone yeah oh
yeah so let me finally figured it out I
think so but now I've got a new one
which is kind of exciting and I hope it
keeps up yeah I hope so too
I should have it here in a moment Salome
people uh someone wait in here I think
my counsel weighed in on the pilot blow
job offer Jesus you had your you
retained counsel Jana to to negotiate
with me right um
right so this is the email that I think
your counsel received
okay dear mrs. to jiske this is the
water champ personality had pretty much
everything champs representation we have
picked up mr. Segura on a pro bono basis
because of said champion Asst and such
find that he is fully deserving of
everything he's issued head slash now
down to brass tacks we counter proposed
since the main Mommy has to do something
he doesn't wish to do refrain from
obtaining his pilot license so should
you in likeness after all
justice is I for an eye all I'm sure as
I'm sure mrs. ogre is sickened by the
fact that he'll be missing out on his
license and the forty forty hours of
instruction we kind of propose you must
watch and listen to 40 hours of vomiting
and try to be going to no later than one
year time furthermore you must listen
and watch vomiting and dry heaving for
at least two hours per year thereafter
to counterbalance all the splendors
missus the girl we miss might be not
becoming a pilot clearly don't frown
white brown and associates dope while
your counsels are really got a stupid
argument well let's see what your
counsel replies with now here's what I'm
thinking you are in the midst of
negotiating for the blowjob pilot
license and
we know that there's gonna be a lot of
back-and-forth and no one's going to
settle on the first offer wondering if
we can throw this into the mix as well
introducing the model one service droid
from Arlen robotics engineered to
perform the most intimate pleasurable
human interaction discreetly at a price
you can afford
yeah this way you don't have to do as
much right did she get to wear the
hiking boots and the ring whatever you
want to put her in I love that parka
that winter wonderland blow job why she
why the the rain boots and a partly I
think it's hard to get blowjobs out out
of ladies after a long hike is that why
I think that because right if you go
like what's going on as a psychic in
right hand dang right like oh no we just
hiked all day and like hey can I get
that BJ now and she's like tired pretty
tired and pretty dirty I really liked it
you know till we wake Lee get back to
civilization yeah and you're like let's
pitch always has a fucking excuse yeah
that camping fantasy is top on the
youporn stuff well you strip all that
stuff away all you got is this so you
know not a sexual features a fully
adjustable body hiding in plain sight
disguised as a cushion and model robot
warrior it's designed to be assembled in
seconds all it takes the folded blanket
over the bottle other clothing garment
of your choice to create a model so real
and gloves will feel like another human
in the room with you oh boy that is the
saddest thing I've ever seen ha Bree
laughs I was so joyful fingertip control
allows speeds ranging from gentle
foreplay to a punishing 125 9 a diamond
but with enough system latency to be
safely stock yes a man the soft flexible
entry gives smooth access complete with
semi-hard teeth Knight hung and throat
auditory is a very holistic experience
mmm seems like a lot of funny this is
this is all we think about it yeah many
use their intellect to create things to
make them come that's how the internet
was developed it's just I need to come
and do the cumin it's pretty maze mm-hmm
school acid and in turn is really the
urban flow there I didn't know it
unrestricted whoa the exit tube can be
covered with a fingertip oh yeah you
super by toe curling suction on demand
oh so you can it's like hitting a bong
you know like you know you just cover up
the church you're here the air there I'm
so disturbed the up to 100% human hair
is this hatch securely flowing directly
from inside the model skin this can be
washed shampooed iron cut it well dialed
anyway designed plunging your fingers
through the thick luxurious soft hair
you and all the baguettes are plastic
containers vibrating balls or rings that
provide such a natural sensation oh
nothing can imitate that gentle rhythmic
caressing motion the head on the cat
kind of makes you sad a little bit
though what do you like much I mean it
is the happiest doll ever for how many
people are like fucking finally you know
how many want them to bosom what's the
price tag I mean that's yeah that's got
it cost like 10 grand that looks like
it's expensive Tsubaki said reasonable
we didn't get to the real price goodbye
my thinking is if you can pay for that
why not just pay for an actual woman to
do that for you that's a good point yeah
I guess I said this thing you know you
can just have it for you don't have to
call again yeah here's the thing it's
like you can wash this hair first of all
you know dudes aren't going to wash her
hair and they're not going to clean out
the mousie that's the problem real
problems yeah they're gonna nut nothing
and I'll be like oh no it's growing
mushrooms why is it run yeah why is
nothing yeah I didn't smell OH you can't
really trust men with this sort of
technology like this is not a good idea
that smells is going to be for ya know
here's that here's the real here's what
you need a certain really thank you
those bad as I'm saying well here's a
service that needs to happen there needs
to be an app and you can order the
machine to be delivered when taken away
oh isn't it and then you leave it out
front
huh like in a hotel when you wave the to
take out with a dining right services
stuff just throwing I've done that yeah
that's the service not disposable one of
these that's another yeah disposable
head okay you go ahead in the trash and
then garbage comes on Monday and they're
like this is chicks female doll heads in
the trash
open either this comes drawn all over
that's the solution I had a crazy
weekend Jesus who feel better though go
way better right yeah that's the
solution
there's no way dudes are maintaining
that thing's hair and mouth no no no
guys are the best thing real fuckin
animals yeah come on we the guy that's
going to do that
you didn't she's a real neat freak real
socialized person thinks about stuff
like that
hell no hell doesn't know he's cutting
up cats in the basement somewhere oh
yeah first come on Oh Nia what's going
on so what I wanted to play for you oh
you had an email to read I read a mitt
no you were going to read me all right
you said that you read an email and well
look for one sin in my life being an
asshole really paid off and I'll show
you like tell me what my wonderful
demeanor
I've saved lies as it says here mommy
Tina saved my life please Wow yep yep my
dearest mommy's nothing but love tea
buns but this email is about how my main
mommy Christina saved my life I can't
reference the episode but Christina made
a comment then changed my life I am
paraphrasing and I'm far too lazy to
find the episode but a comment was made
that if you are 400 pounds you either
need to get your life or go for a world
record at the time I heard this I was
406 pounds Wow in the heat of the moment
I hated her for the comment that opinion
quickly changed after a good night's
sleep I couldn't shake her words and
decided for the first time in my life I
was going to make a positive decision I
decided that I didn't want to be one of
these fat fucks that needs to be fork
lifted out of their home after a series
of heart attacks decided to actually do
something about it that morning I joined
a weight-loss program for men huge shout
out to Harvey Brooker in Toronto there
couldn't have done it without you
started to take my diet seriously and
got off my ass and started working out
at the time of this email I am pleased
to say that I am now down 100 pound
amazing and pushing for 100 pounds more
I sent an email assembly thank resina
for the inadvertent inadvertent
motivation to get my shit together she
honestly extended my
life by making an off-the-cuff remark
and is directly responsible for
improving my quality of life I don't run
my more active confident and a straight
up pussy Slayer but my dong looks
significantly bigger and I can fuck for
a straight three minutes without
breaking a sweat
there you go so thank you it isn't now
see what's his name Johnny Johnny
congratulate thanks Johnny
that is great you're done 100 pounds
like Chinese Mayo that's been time
that's amazed a hundred pounds dude
congratulation so you said this is the
shit unforeseen episode to celebrate
Kristina episode yeah I mean you know I
sometimes I just even with drop pearls
your nose our personnel yeah you help
that guy out I would say because I help
people I have the better personality
definitely a personality champ somebody
probably nothing but helping people
right in here is the real champ
breakdown well Jesus wasn't here you
greedy mommy's you both can't be the
chance of everything no I went until you
as a favor and broke it down I listened
to your podcast in the car and when I
get carts of that food line so I got
this shit okay burp champ this is Tom
wrong this is evident throughout the
podcast he has variety volume and a hoe
so perfect pitch FA RT champ Christina
thank you listen Tom had that one fart
on the mighty the reason it was
immaculate but mommy team latina seems
to have her farts down a water champ Tom
Ron I should know I have to explain this
wrong we know he downs gallons of water
every day and Devon Joe Rogan that's a
witness to his water madam drinking
personality champ Christina she just
seems phi sir special amber she just
seems nicer damn I don't know fuck you
that's what he wrote on there you go I
am nice and Glasson champ quickly no
thank you
I know this hasn't been brought up thank
you but come on Tina is always writing
down notes
thank you very observant and it is a
necessity for Glasson if I miss a
championship please let me know and I
will analyze the evidence thanks for the
show love you mommies keep it high and
motherfucking tight Davis now we never
brought up the glass and champ
discussion but I like it
I'm definitely way more observant than
you though knowing you are not oh I'm so
observant no you're not you miss
everything Natalie everything you're not
observing I'm so much more observant of
my surroundings I know it what's
happened you don't pick up all I pick up
on stuff all that you're really I pick
up on that yeah yeah I know you pick up
on like a nail the head but like you
don't pick up on subtle cues you know
Alan little behavior nuances of him s
voice of inflection of saying this and
they meant that so look that you don't
pick up on any other Minds like I care
for a toddler a lot and I pick up on
what he needs he can't talk I'm very
sensitive yeah yeah oh oh look at you
all of a sudden I'm a stay-at-home dad
for two whole days and I don't find the
mom champ I don't think you're the very
observant person I'm so much more
observant oh there is a guy he's a doing
new video he drenched I had pizza on
ranch yeah not bad good yeah you spatter
definitely definitely is in public
there's my sure is it's weird to make
this video in public right well maybe
that's the new thing you know it always
at all he's letting on the trip on his
shirt we're saying the king a stripper
eat by the way thank you there's some
fried chicken eating definitely in a
public setting yeah yeah hear that
there's people around
yeah it's kind of weird that he would do
a good guy oh wow man
he's just stuffing it's hard to watch
him eat I know
honestly I'm not really into the eating
videos much as I like the farts the vote
I don't like Trevor yeah he's really
sure thank you thank you
fascinating working with Goldman
fascinating yeah
all right making eye contact to the
camera look at a restaurant oh yeah yeah
in a restaurant I got a good back table
yeah did I get thinking room Oh
even the bow fighting that so he went to
a buffet so he's still making videos
yeah god bless him I miss him I know I'm
glad he's back
it's really weird didn't see him not
wearing tighty whities I know it's weird
to see him out in public I didn't think
he did that yeah I thought he just
stayed in this basement all the time
just farted on stuff yeah
bargain credenzas and such I feel like
that's like old now that's just it's not
the same anymore
well you evolve he's an artist who
changes can't expect him to stay the
same somebody wrote thanks for making me
dream I'm pleased to inform you that for
the first time in my entire life I had a
dream about taking a shit and it's all
thanks to you oh wow listening to
episode 392 on a long late car ride home
last night
I got home I promptly fell asleep and
had a very involved dream in which I was
a young I was in a yoga class I had to
make brown the toilet was in the middle
of the class for some reason and not
only did the instructor call my
attention to my shitting but I was so
embarrassed that I went to wipe with my
balled up TP and absolutely got shit on
my hand
mmm I've been a lifelong toilet paper
water up until today you gotten into my
psyche inception style and now I feel I
can finally get my life thanks jeans
Kaitlin well I wasn't even expecting
that to be a lady no me neither
no lady oh yeah or maybe I mean is
Kaitlin maybe it's the Kaitlin maybe
could be which is obviously still a lady
I didn't mean to suggest that oh my god
save the hate the hell offended please
please save the hate mail oh my what you
pronounced with your pronoun um okay
anything else Jean um no thanks for
Webber came out to see me and thank you
to those who will come out to see me
absolutely go mm ranch calm to get
tickets to see Christina Tom Segura calm
for my
dates also my store is there if you want
to pick up anything I mentioned there's
the excited I might even listen to is it
mostly stories you have to say I have
two bonus tracks weather the winter can
you say what they're about I recorded
them in Chicago when I did the Chicago
show where Chicago and what do they
became give me just one is the follow-up
so that so in the special I talked about
meeting Mike Tyson yeah and people
always gave me like would email me what
happened next
so I tell the follow-ups oh that's fat
that's wonderful you should have said
that earlier as exciting so you get give
kind of the the insider scoop on of what
Eleniak the whole thing yeah because I
am the special with the phone hanging up
and then like what happened not going to
tell the story and then the other thing
is I talk about I talk about making a
murderer the your life yeah the Netflix
show very cool well that's exciting
very excitement yeah so Thomas grow calm
go to the store or you can download the
album if you want so I'm going to
extreme it I don't know however you do
it the glass and poster your mom's house
podcast calm please don't forget to
check that out Amazon please do your
shopping using our banner go to your
mom's house podcast calm click on the
banner to bottom the home page to your
shopping as you normally would as always
I remind people that there is YouTube if
you want to watch the show people seem
to not know that for some reason and I'm
always going to solicit that you write a
review of the show on iTunes so if you
don't mind just write a review on the
show only 5 and jeans it up like some
jeans II read up about it
check out that deep brow - if you're so
inclined I actually am very nice on that
show and help people with their lives
how people get their lives even with a
sour personality she's doing good work
alright thanks for listening we'll see
you next week here is
[Music]
we all do what we stand
and every another wall have you not
allow we have another Wow Wow take it
over
[Music]